[Music]
this story is just crazy i don't know
how the [ __ ] something like this could
happen
but it did
someone got their head stuck in a peanut
butter jar
yeah that's crazy
did you do that once
no
he seems like the type your whole head
it's a big jar huh that's a family-sized
yarn man
so pennsylvania high school principal
the principal's 34 years old right how
the [ __ ] does that even happen already i
was like i know a 34 year old principal
yep he uh apparently had a sexual
relationship with a 16 year old student
that lasted for seven plus years
wait so they've been doing this and they
were nine she was nine no we just
started started at 16.
extended after graduation
so is that considered a long-term
relationship then yeah
i don't even know what you they got
anniversaries bro wait is there even
like a term i don't know she's an adult
now though right so does that make it i
know it's an issue they're both they're
both men
but they're both adults now yes and
they're both still together
i don't know if they're still together
currently but it it lasted up until
college okay
so 23. okay what are they trying to do
to him what do you mean he's because i
have two thoughts a principle one is
like obviously it's [ __ ] up he was
like uh like being a predator to like a
16 year old right
but then if they made it
it's weird
but i'm like i guess like
i don't know 50 or hundred years ago
that's not a weird age imagine their
story so how do you guys meet
we met in homeroom
taken role this happened with a lady
so this lady teacher
she got didn't she get pregnant with the
student yeah and then and then she she
did her time and afterwards they got
married or something right and i was
super weird but they were he was already
adult and then they the relationship
made it but they divorced later when she
got really old remember really i think
so this is the one that had the kid we
did she passed away i think too right oh
okay okay mary kay luterno
that's her name yeah
yeah this is a little weirder
he uh so he was released on bail how
much do you think the bill is by the way
fifty thousand fifty five dollars fifty
five dollars
i had the same number in my head that's
cheaper than a parking ticket eight
thousand dollars
wait why is he in jail
why isn't he no why is he in jail the
principal yeah uh here's his charges
that's stupid question uh no it's not
stupid um alleged sexual contact with a
student corruption of a minor furnishing
liquor to a minority no it's stupid yeah
aggravated indecent assault without
consent
yeah because because the kid was 16 when
they started doing this yeah
that's the big issue and you can't be a
principal and do that to a student even
if there's there's no consent yeah how
did he get caught
um
does not say how he kept posting about
him on his instagram because it's a
criminal it's a criminal case right like
he's going to jail he went to jail so
there was a case that was built up
against him
and then he had to get caught and all
this stuff and then um
i mean when it's a criminal case it's
regardless if they press charges i think
he just still violated the law and then
so it's the city yeah exactly exactly so
even if like even if there was no
uh even if they were still lovers yeah
or whatever it doesn't matter it doesn't
matter because he still violated yeah
and he was a pet right and got caught it
doesn't even matter because at that age
you don't even have the ability to give
consent so everything that's taking
place
it's completely legal and then it's a
state versus you if you did and then
okay so 23 and then had the relationship
for you know seven years
yeah so twenty thousand dollars
175 actually
175
bucks
yeah for yeah uh i was close i was 55
dollars it's not 175 000. i'm just
saying five thousand okay okay good 175
000. i was like what the [ __ ] 175 bucks
i'm like that's [ __ ] like
cosmopolitan on tuesday
they only pay like 10 percent of the
bond or thing yeah for sure for sure
bonded out yeah of course what what was
the um the thing again if like let's say
like um a 17 year old
in high school was dating like a 21 year
old in college what's that situation out
here yeah it would still be i think not
is it there is there a three year grace
period kind of dating or having sex like
oh no sex statutory rape that's
considered statutory rape even if it's
consensual well because that's a minor
yeah what about if uh
when you started dating you were both
like the guy was like 17 and the girl
was like 15. as long as you're not
asking for sex yeah yeah
i am 15 right
now to know
seven you try to date up right wait no
they're not 18.
if they were 18 then it's statutory rate
but if they're 17 and then they're but
that's what i'm saying
oh that that's
huh 17 no no but his question is 15 and
17. well my mic they're just minor but
we we already answered the first
question because we already said that
was right but if let's say you were both
minors and then you were together and
then obviously you aged together but one
of them is one guy one reached
before the other
yeah 18 and the other one's still 17. it
would still be statutory rape if you
have sex and it's it's under disapproval
of your parents right if there are cases
like that yeah there are cases and it's
different to state to state isn't it
let's say the minor who's 17 has parents
that go
you can't have sex because
your partner's now 18 and you still do
it now it's under disapproval of the
parent the parent can press charges even
though they might have had sex together
before the guy turned 18 or whatever
yeah you could i think it's state by
state case too because i know logistics
that if it's within a three-year period
so like let's say you're 18 and then
they're
17
then it's like it's something else but
then if it's under 15 and then you're 18
then that's something else like there's
different categories to it got it as far
as like level of charges i think there's
different names that like statutory and
whatever whatever because that's gotta
happen all the time right it's like
you're dating in high school somebody's
a little bit older they go to college
now you're an adult yeah i remember that
happening in my school like it happened
all the time but then like of course
that meant usually that the relationship
was already kind of under approval by
the parents so the parents it wasn't a
red flag it was just like oh we already
like it so the guardians may come and
play in a situation even if you're both
underage and one guardian doesn't
approve of the relationship they can do
something legally to stop it if there's
sex involved even if even if they
suspect they're sex evolved
you don't even have to prove it because
at that point it's like if you're just a
parent and you're like no i don't
approve of this thing whatever it is but
you know what you're getting something
you could legally do something about i
don't know if it's going to succeed i
thought you could also marry at 16.
maybe look
maybe with the consent of your parents
or permission it really comes down to
just like if you're a minor it all comes
down to parental [ __ ] that's why like
and in the emancipation thing too right
can't you be
like emancipated at under 18 and then
become like a full-on oh i think you can
but doesn't that also have to be proven
if like your parents are like i don't
know abusive or do some random [ __ ] or
something like that and then you could
somebody has to sign off on it man
there's so many crazy rules yeah i don't
even really
i'm just going off of when i was
underage and we were really asking all
these questions all the time yeah the
teachers always just say it just comes
down to what your parents are okay with
and what they're not okay with because
you guys are kids what if you're 19 can
you still go on field trips no actually
if you're did you sign the permission
well you could be the chaperone and
you're technically you know i remember
when at school dances in high school
if you wanted to bring somebody else
that was older you would have to get
like a bunch of different signatures
yeah you hit signature and sign off and
i think the cap was like up to 21 at my
house at our at our high school i saw it
winning
what kind of disgusting five year old
what's going on yeah i think i might say
that to my sister's ex-boyfriend for
real yeah he was 25 going to like
homecoming she was getting older
i mean that's like that was a long time
ago but there was definitely a period
where it's like i was like dang you know
when you're like young and you're
looking at like a 25 year old in your
eyes
oh you're a dinosaur you know what i
mean
so i remember hella having feelings like
that because i remember she was maybe
like 16 17 was dating like a 23 or 24
year old i just thought that everyone
that was 17 was trying to date up not
down well she was trying to do that she
was younger well guys and girls right
well
but then guys
i don't know like when i was when i was
in college
as soon as i broke that barrier high
school girls weren't even on my mind
anymore because like college girls were
like well high school girls can't even
go out [ __ ] late but then it's like
you're in college age now you want
everyone older yeah yeah well there was
a really interesting thing that happened
in my school where uh
one of my uh friends in my class she was
uh
uh had a date for the banquet
who was i think 25 or some [ __ ] like mad
old this dude would look like
[ __ ] tom hanks or some [ __ ]
we're like this guy's hella old and we
were all like making fun of him and [ __ ]
and then um
i was like i remember thinking how the
[ __ ] is that possible yeah because how's
that allowed yeah we were all seniors
and i think she was even with him from
her junior year i was like the [ __ ] is
this and that it's not that it was that
their age gap was so big
i wasn't tripping about that i was
tripping why the school let him come to
the thing
come to find out years later
she had like been held back so much that
she was actually a lot [ __ ] older oh
like she was 23.
oh okay yeah she just looked and i think
the school was trying to like let her
you know do what she was able to do but
also not out her to her class that she
had like failed or something she's
actually her husband yeah she was like
they didn't want to embarrass her and be
like oh by the way it's okay because
she's really this [ __ ] old you know
like so they spared her rep that way and
i didn't find out it's a way later and
it said everybody judged the school
yeah they took they took the hit yeah
because we were all like that's [ __ ]
that's what schools are supposed to be
about you know i mean that guy's at the
school dance with the [ __ ] norelco
it's just
stupid
he's all doing his taxes like what is
this guy doing here
he's all predicting the [ __ ] economy
and [ __ ] he's like you know in 2008 the
housing bubble
look what the [ __ ] are you talking about
that's that's so weird because for me i
always wanted older and older
until i hit mid 20s then i started going
oh younger girls are pretty hot
so like when i was like from maybe 15 or
16 i'm like oh i want a upper class i
want an upper class because i was like
if i'm if i'm a junior i want a senior
if i'm a senior i want to get a college
girl you want premium yeah
i try to jail bait myself in high school
yeah
i couldn't do it that's how you do it
yeah cause they usually girls usually
want older guys you know yeah they're
longer younger yeah yeah yeah i've never
dated younger you've never dated younger
your whole life wow yeah that's what i'm
saying i feel like it's normal for girls
it's always like three or four years
older minimum minimums wow
that's what you said or that's just what
happened
no that's my personal experience
oh by design or by like by choice oh
okay
so you have you ever met a guy that was
like oh you're great but
you're just like
the same not old enough you know like no
i've actually never met um a guy that
was younger than me that i was
interested in oh so you just won't even
feel the magic i clearly can't got it
that's pretty cool when i was 19 my my
girlfriend was
23. when i was 19 she was 23. i only had
this one piece of tattoo she already had
sleeves from her [ __ ] shoulders all
the way to her wrist
and then this was during the time when
like tattoos weren't that dude that's
super uncommon back then right yeah and
then so she was already 23. she had all
that she had a big [ __ ] trance stamp
of her ex-boyfriend on her back right oh
yeah you told us about this big hardcore
[ __ ] right yeah it said bart on it
remember
but but
you're picturing a six foot biker chick
all right i'm it's it's it's it was
really a five two petite asian girl yeah
i was picturing large marge from the
peewee movie
but um i remember thinking wow i got an
older girl finally right and she's
[ __ ] hot
and you know we had a great relationship
it was [ __ ] awesome until we got no
argument she got a [ __ ] flower pot
and smashed it over the back of my head
and i was like damn this girl is feisty
she's strong for 24 years
um but uh still still love her that's
not why you broke up no no no she broke
up with me oh because
i
wasn't thinking about my future
and i was too young didn't she just
almost end your future i know okay
and then she became
you're not thinking about your future
i still love you
and then she married a a muslim man and
and converted to islam and then became
actually very
um wholesome yeah
very
of that wholesome she she became muslim
and became
you